Peter Gregory Obi a former governor of
anambra state is the youngest of the
Front Runners to be Nigeria's next
president
his campaign message seems to resonate
with young voters who say they are tired
of the politics of the world
we want to secure and unite Nigeria
we want to
transform Nigeria from his presence
cost because consumption the productive
country
a successful businessman he broke away
from the party that made him governor
and one that chose him as a presidential
running mate to lead the labor party's
presidential campaign
has a similar shift from the major
parties the one that doesn't control any
legislature or state
the nnpp candidate is a former Defense
Minister and was governor of Nigeria's
second most popular state Kano for eight
years
the election now is between the big
names who have destroyed this country
and people who are looking for an
alternative
the 2023 election isn't business as
usual the two new contenders and their
supporters believe they can unseat the
governing party just like in 2015 when
the opposition won the opponents say
they can only divert votes from the main
political parties some analysts expect
the two to force a runoff and with
skillful negotiations when or even
decide who becomes president
[Music]
this is a man Nigeria's opposition is
trying to stop
a former governor of Nigeria's
commercial and business Capital Bola
Ahmed tinubu is credited with
transforming Lagos State and
restructuring its economy the governing
party flag bearer says he wants to
replicate this at the national level
security
economy
foreign policy is secondary building
relationship given the other country
assurance
believing in the sanctity of contract
both tinibo and Obi are making the most
of a belief by some Nigerians that the
presidency should head south after being
held by a northerner for eight years
as supporters of the former vice
president atiku abubakar say Nigeria's
democracy must not be defined by
Regional sentiments a retired Customs
officer Mr abubakar is a successful
businessman with interest in
manufacturing and service Industries he
wasn't available for interview
the manifestos and ideologies of all the
political parties are similar but there
are at least new contenders for the
presidency which in itself could make
politicians in Africa's most populous
country more accountable to their voters
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera Abuja